[Applause]
hot off the wire today and it's funny
because in the commercial break i'm like
wait i'm obsessed with your shoes where
did you get them
i got them on dsw
so
i i'm uh i don't wear leather and it's
hard it's often hard to find you know
shoes a lot of things have leather and
so um many companies though are now
making things that are pleather and to
me i don't need to wear leather to wear
a fun green heel and there it is
love that
[Music]
and it has nothing to do with the fact
that this story has hit the wire um but
like okay so apparently all day people
are freaking out on twitter and
instagram and social media and every
portal about your jacket um but did you
know that your hair and outfit were
making like i did i did not i mean it's
everywhere my mother actually mentioned
this to me before it was anywhere else
maybe she started it she said i noticed
you didn't wear a blazer you wore a
sweater and i said what is she talking
about i said i always wear a blazer and
then i thought it was the sweater blazer
there it is
that's a sweater well it's like sweatery
material yeah oh it's it's very lovely
very beautiful color it's a shocking
color but it was autumn so
i was gonna say a lot of people are
saying oh she's already worn that jacket
and she's wearing it again with no
attitude no negativity there's nothing
slanderous or or upsetting about it just
an absolute observant obsessive
commenting about how you repeated a
jacket
i mean it's look you know for for men in
these hosting positions they they also
change clothes every episode but they
wear you know a blue suit a gray suit a
black suit and they just like change the
ties it's less noticeable but like also
like i like when people repeat something
because that's what normal life is
you know what's not normal life
is like
being able to change your outfit i mean
this top i've worn several times on the
show these pants they're dusty at this
point i wear them so often like that's
what we do we mix and match and pair
um so i've never worn this this is just
for you
and i will never wear that blazer again
that's it
it's done well apparently if you do
they're going to notice
now with all the reboots going on have
you ever considered a blossom reboot
um
so
we
we we have not we've not had a
conversation about a full reboot um don
rio who created blossom and was our
executive producer for years um he and i
actually well he he has um a dramatic
script with the characters from blossom
that he and i have been working on for
years
um it's it's a very it would be a very
different way to think of a reboot but
on call me cat our first episode of the
season we had um joey lawrence and jenna
vanoy and michael stoyanov on and
i'll go ahead and i'll give you a little
fun reveal you're the first one i'm
telling in our finale ted wass who
played my dad on blossom is playing
cat's father in a fantasy sequence
so it's like a full circle blossom
i mean we're very excited also for us
it's just like a sweet little book end
to season two that we started with you
know the cast of blossom and we're
ending and ted was also a very
accomplished director and so for him to
like come out of acting kind of
retirement and come um to play cat's dad
we're very very excited so i would need
things to quiet down a little in my life
so that i'm not also holding two jobs i
also have a podcast called miami alex
breakdown which is
this is very busy listen to the podcast
too it is full of life revelations one
of which i've been the beneficiary
because i'm a listener and everything
that you do we are here for it thank you
that's very sweet my empty alex
as they made us her gorgeous writer
director
you know film that's very personal is in
theaters and on demand now with a
stellar cast and a beautiful approach to
storytelling it really is and you are
just i love you sir
[Music]